you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross vice
president of evangelism for amazing
facts good evening friends how about an
amazing fact consider for a moment the
ear of the bat it is well known that
bats fly by Sona
they emit high-frequency sounds which
the human ear cannot hear the returning
echo of these sounds place sound print
pictures in their minds using this
technique a bat can catch a tiny fast
flying insect the high the pitch the
small of the surface its echo can reveal
some sounds are so high that the little
bat can detect the presence of a wire no
thicker than a human hair stretched
across its flight path then there is the
intensity of the sound the louder it is
the more distant the object that can't
be detected so these calls are generally
very loud but wait if it is necessary
for a bat to make such a loud sound in
order to have it echo back from a
distant object how can the bat possibly
hear the echo with its ears in the midst
of all of the racket it is making with
its mouth while this is a good question
for the ear of the bat is extremely
sensitive just a few of these loud
screams would quickly definite but God
has taken care of the problem there is a
special muscle in the middle ear of the
bat that is attached to one of three
tiny bones which transmit vibrations
from the eardrum to the organ in the
skull that convert them to nerve signals
that are sent to the brain just as each
scream is on the verge of being emitted
this muscle instantly pulls back on one
of these tiny bones so that it does not
transmit sound from the outer ear to the
inner year
the eardrum is momentarily disconnected
then after the scream ends that muscle
relaxants and the bone moves back into
place thus the only sound that the bat
actually hears is its own echo this back
and forth motion of this little bone
occurs more than 100 times a second and
it always occurs in perfect alignment
with the sending of the super-short
screams now friends if God cares enough
about the common bat to provide it with
this remarkable ability to hear its own
echo how much more does he care for you
stay tuned for more as amazing facts
brings you this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 lated question
the phone line here to the studio is one
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven I'll give you that number
again as we go through the program but
make sure you write it down the number
is eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven that will bring you right
here to the studio with your Bible
question I'll be giving you another
number which is our free offer number
for our different resources and I'll
give you that number in just a moment
but let me talk about our amazing fact
we talked about this remarkable little
muscle in the inner ear of the back that
can actually separate the eardrum of the
bat from the inner ear so that it can
just hear its echo it's really a
remarkable thing and all this happens in
just a few moments every second more
than a hundred times and of course God
is the one who designed this and built
this ability for the bat and there's a
lesson in that for us the Bible tells us
in Matthew chapter 10 verse 29 it's
actually Jesus speaking he says on are
two sparrows sold for a copper coin and
not one of them falls to the ground
apart from your father's will
but the very hairs of your head are all
numbered
do not fear therefore you are more
valuable than many sparrows you think
about the remarkable design that's
involved in the creatures that God is
made you got the birds
you got the bats you got the flowers the
trees everything so delicately designed
how much more does God care about you
we have a book that talks about
assurance God's love for us and also the
plan of redemption it is a book written
by Pastor Doug and this is our free
offer this evening you'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
all you have to do is call 883 five six
seven four seven and ask for the book
called assurance justification made
simple that number again is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you can ask for the book assurance
written by pastor Doug we'll be happy to
send this out to anyone who calls and
asks and if you have a Bible question
our phone line here to the studio again
he's eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven that you bring in here
and you'll be able to talk about your
Bible question again that number is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven and with that I think we're
ready to go to the phone lines our first
caller that we have is let's see we have
mark listening from looks like Canada
mark welcome to the program yes well hi
mark you on the air hi my question is I
see pastor Doug's not there or yes
pastor Mike's out of town um my question
was because lately and several of his
broadcasts he's made reference to
unfallen worlds and I was just wondering
where in the Bible we might find some
information on that yeah that's a good
question we do have several references
actually that talked about these beings
not from our world but from other worlds
in job chapter 1 verse 6 it talks about
a gathering together and this is job
chapter 1 verse 6 it says now there was
a day when the sons of God came to
present themselves before the Lord and
Satan also came among them so it's
describing a meeting that occurs
somewhere
the universe probably in heaven and it
talks about this group of people are
calls than the sons of God the
representatives of these other worlds
and then Satan shows up and he's
claiming to represent the earth and God
asked the question if you considered my
servant job and of course Satan says
well the only reason he serves you is
because all of the blessings he have
bestowed upon him and then you have the
whole story of job play out so some have
seen in the sons of God that spoken of
en job has been the representatives are
these unfallen worlds you can also read
in the book of hebrews hebrews chapter 1
where it's speaking about creation in
christ it says that through him he
created the worlds and it uses the
plural word therefore worlds so our
world is not the only world that God
created it appears as though there are
other worlds and there are other created
beings other than angels angels
typically abide in heaven but there are
the worlds we think our world is the
only one that has fallen prey to Satan's
deceptions these other worlds probably
have resisted Satan's temptations they
are faithful to God they're also seen as
the 24 elders that are described in
Revelation Revelation chapter 4 talks
about these 24 elders and some seen that
the representatives of the unfallen
world and in Psalms we read about how
that the Lord reigns before his elders
gloriously so when you put these
different verses together it comes to
light that there are these unfallen
worlds and they are the representatives
of the unfolding worlds there in heaven
witnessing the great controversy being
played out here on the earth very
interesting thank you yeah absolutely
you know we do have a book actually pass
a Doug wrote a book yeah and it's called
the sons of God who are the sons of God
and it talks about this year in
diversity particularly in job as well as
some of the other references and mark
we'd be happy to send that to you all
you have to do is call us on our
resource phone line that number is 885
six seven four seven and as for the book
called who are the sons of God again
that number is 885 six seven four seven
and if you have a Bible question we do
have a few lines still open the
collies 804 six three seven two nine
seven that's 800 four six three seven
two nine seven next question or next
caller that we have is let's see we have
Robert listening in Tennessee Robert
welcome to the program hi hi Robert
and your question tonight I have a
question about in psalm of solomon i
first chapter 7 verse 3 it mentions the
the gentleman who is speaking of his
potential bride he's mentioning her
breasts are like two fawns twins of a
gazelle okay he is mentioning a part of
the female body that is actually for
child feeding would that be to say that
because is using he is you know thinking
of her in a different way than the you
know her breasts were meant to be for
feeding children he's thinking of him in
a sexual way is that actually considered
what you would say I don't know
perversion okay I don't think good
question I don't yeah let me share a
little bit about that
some of Solomon is a very interesting
book and it clearly there's several
themes that you can see in there there's
definitely the love of a husband and a
wife that that's pretty evident there an
intimacy that God originally designed
for a husband and wife but it also has
spiritual meaning or spiritual
applications in the Bible the church is
described as the Bride of Christ and the
groom is described as Jesus so you can
also find that the purpose of the church
is to first of all to be committed to
Christ to be fully surrendered to Christ
and then the church is to reflect his
character to the world and to grow to do
evangelism and to produce so to speak
other believers in Christ and so you've
got somewhat of that parallel Song of
Solomon is a very descriptive passage it
is written in poetic for
and so there's some poetic language
that's used in the description that you
find here and yeah it is a book that
deals with romance and the marriage
relationship and it's one of those those
interesting books that yes sometimes you
gotta depending on your audience where
you want to read from that book because
it is pretty descriptive in some ways to
be honest with you you know we just need
to be careful we do have a live program
here and we have all kinds of audience
listening so you got to be careful on
where we go with that I would encourage
folks that did like read it for yourself
take a look at the book of Song of
Solomon and there's a lot of interesting
comments there that I think need to be
looked at in its proper context of
course that's true for any subject that
you're studying in the Bible you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven makes
philippi heavy Sam you listening from
Wisconsin Sam you're welcome to the
program yes thank you for taking my call
hi thanks for calling in your question
this evening yes in Genesis chapter 2
verse three two and three were God
rested on the Sabbath yes after its
creation that before I was a sunday
keeper but after listening to your
program and seeing that the importance
that God had rested blessed and
sanctified it is that the only to be the
Lord rested in the Bible it is
especially in the sense of creation so
God created the earth in six days Adam
Eve were created on the sixth day and
then God rested on the seventh day and
if you look at the fourth commandment in
Exodus chapter 20 it says remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days the
Lord God made the heavens the earth the
sea and everything in it and then he
rested on the seventh day and he
sanctified it to sanctify something
means to set it apart for a holy use so
God set aside the seventh day he rested
on that day now God did not read
because it was exhausted in creating the
earth then God just spoke things into
being but the rest spoken of here in
Genesis chapter 2 is a rest of
satisfaction it is completion his work
was perfect the Bible says it was very
good and God rested from the work of
creating and as a memorial of his
creative work the Sabbath was
established way back even before sin
entered the world and of course that's
reflected in the Ten Commandments you
have the fourth commandment that talks
about that you go to the New Testament
again the Sabbath he's spoken of Jesus
kept the Sabbath you find the Sabbath
mentioned many times in the book of Acts
and so we find the Sabbath theme from
creation all the way through the Bible
and then if you look at some of the
prophetic passages that talk about the
earth made new it again brings up the
Sabbath that God's people will keep the
Sabbath in the earth we created that's
the only time God rested in the Bible
well yes
at least from the work of creation where
God rested late that's what was curious
but that answered my question and Shalom
to you brother all right absolutely
thanks for your Col Samuel appreciated
our next caller that we have is let's
see we've got Bill listening in Chicago
bill welcome to the program billed
you're on the air bill in Chicago going
once going twice
alright we might have to come back to
you bill let's see we've got Alvin I
believe it is listening in Brooklyn
wrong look there it is yes
hi and welcome to the program yeah doing
very well thank you that you're not here
today pastor doug is out of town
he might be listening for all we know
but he's not here in the studio okay
the millennion yes we are some are those
who believe that the thousand years
period of in connection with the
description of Christ's second return to
reign with the Saints as recorded in
Revelation 20
first one to nine they are defined in
different sectors to me it is making the
subject a little bit difficult to
understand for some there are teachings
of a millennium post-millennial and
premillennial yes with the youth band
and all right well let me watch relation
and what relation of it with the
tribulation okay good question let me
give a little background for our
listeners it might not be that familiar
with the subject of the Millennium the
word millennium doesn't appear in the
Bible but it's a Latin it means a
thousand years and the bible does speak
of a special thousand year period and
the key passage for this is Revelation
chapter 20 sometimes the question is
asked well oh what's happening on the
earth during the thousand years or where
are the righteous during the thousand
years
that's the tribulation precede the
millennium how does that all fit
together well if you look at the
sequence as given in the book of
Revelation and some other passages in
the New Testament the time of trouble or
the tribulation precedes the second
coming of Christ and here's a few verses
Daniel chapter 12 verse 1 it says at
that time Michael shall stand up the
Great Prince who stands watch over the
sons of thy people and there will be a
time of trouble worse than the world has
ever seen but at that time thy people
shall be delivered every one found
written in the book so here in Daniel 12
it talks about a time worse than the
world has ever seen
and that God's people are delivered
meaning they are delivered through that
time of trouble they're protected during
those plagues that fall upon the earth I
call it the seven last plagues that you
can read about in Revelation chapter 15
16 and then Jesus comes you have the
second coming of Christ Jesus comes and
the righteous are taken to heaven you
have the resurrection of the righteous
the Saints who have died they are
resurrected at the second coming those
who are living are changed in a moment
in the twinkling of an eye that quarter
to meet Jesus in the clouds in the air
and they spent a thousand years in
heaven with Christ and they
participating in the judging of the wick
during that time period the condition on
the earth after Jesus comes talks about
the earth being broken down it talks
about the earth is sort of a dark
desolate region actually Revelation
chapter 3 talks about the bottomless pit
is sort of a description of that the
wicked all destroyed by the brightness
of Christ's coming that 2nd
Thessalonians so for a thousand years
the righteous are in heaven the earth
these desolate Satan and his angels are
bound on the earth during that thousand
years at the end of the 1000 year period
you read in Revelation chapter 21 that
the new jerusalem descends from God out
of heaven all the wicked are resurrected
and they stand outside the New Jerusalem
for what we call the great white throne
judgment that you can also read about in
Revelation chapter 20 following the
great white throne judgment finally
every knee bows and every tongue confess
that Jesus is Lord
it's not a repentance either it's more
of an acknowledgment of the facts
because no sooner do they say that when
the devil goes out and is able to
deceive them and they mount their attack
upon the New Jerusalem then it is that
fire comes down from God out of heaven
and devoured them
then God creates a new heavens and a new
earth wherein dwells righteousness so
that's just a quick synopsis of the
different steps that take place during
that time period so I hope that helps
does that make sense yeah but my
question is what his relationship would
be on the tribulation and the the
Millennial well the tribulation occurs
before the Millennium begins the
Millennium begins with the second coming
of Christ when Jesus comes again that
thousand year time period begins you'll
notice the end of Revelation chapter 19
which leads into the thousand years is a
description of the second coming of
Christ where Jesus is described as
coming to execute judgment upon the
wicked that's the second coming then
once Jesus comes and the righteous are
caught up to meet him in the air they go
to heaven for a thousand years the
wicked all destroyed that is the
millennial period that one thousand
years you know we do have a study guide
dealing with the subject
of the millennium and we would be happy
to send that out to anyone who calls and
asks it's called a thousand years of
peace and I think you'll enjoy this
Alvin or anyone who wants to learn more
about what the Bible has to say on this
subject just asked for the study guide
called a thousand years of peace and the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
our resource phone line 808 three five
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the study guide called a thousand years
of peace our next caller that we have is
listening in Lodi California I believe
it's Sean Sean welcome to the program so
thanks for taking my call
thanks ladies trying to gain a better
understanding of the role and purpose of
the hundred and forty-four thousand
especially in an endtime prophecy okay
144,000 are described for us in two
principal passages in Revelation the one
is Revelation chapter 7 and the other is
Revelation chapter 14 the first six
verses talk about 144,000 144,000
they're God's endtime apostles that take
a special warning message to the world
they're alive when Jesus comes the
second time so they are translated to
heaven without seeing death some of the
descriptions given you can find in
Revelation chapter 7 it goes all the way
through to talks about them as part of a
great multitude it says there are a ones
who have gone through great tribulation
I'm looking verse 15 there before the
throne of God they serve Him day and
night and then it says in verse 16 they
neither hunger anymore nor thirst
anymore the Sun does not strike them nor
any Heat by the way that is one of the
plagues is an intense heat it says the
lamb was in the midst of the throne
shall shepherd them and lead them to
living fountains of water God will wipe
away every tear from the eye so they're
God's people in the last days that have
a special work of taking the gospel to
the world especially in the context of
the second coming of Christ
so are they insulated from the endtime
tribulation yes they live through the
seven last
place but they are protected just like
Elijah of old was protected during the
time of the drought that came upon
Israel God provided him water from the
brook Cherith and he had food that was
brought to him by the birds by the
Ravens he was protected from the wrath
of King Ahab and Jezebel so God's people
in the last days those who do this work
of Elijah this endtime evangelistic
Proclamation in the last days they're
protected during that time of universal
judgment and destruction that comes upon
the earth so they're people like you and
I they're not angelic no they they
believe us they people like you and I
you can have more of a description in
Revelation chapter 14 where it talks
about them singing a new song before the
throne before the fall of increas and
the elders no one could learn that song
except 144,000 then it says who were
redeemed from the earth so these are
real people that says these are the ones
who were not defiled it talks about them
being pure it says in their mouth was
found no deceit for they are without
fault before the throne of God so here's
a group of people who have come so close
to Jesus they've allowed the Holy Spirit
to sow in fill them that they reflect
God's character in the last days in a
special way and do a great work of
evangelism absolutely absolutely we want
to be filled with the spirit and and
share the good news with as many people
as we can you know we do have a book
that talks about 144,000 I think you'd
find interesting it's 144,000 who are
they and we'll send you the book for
free all you have to do is just call us
on our resource phone line and that
number is 885 six seven four seven and
this is for anyone anyone can call and
ask as for the book about the hundred
and forty-four thousand again that
number is 885 six seven four seven asked
for the book about the 144,000
next caller that we have is Bill
listening from Chicago bill are you
there yeah hi welcome to the program
calling for some advices I've gotten two
different answers from two different
pastors and so I'm calling to see what
you think all right hey we got about two
minutes before we have to take a break
so what's your question okay um my
question is basically is it okay to go
to church it's the only way you have to
get there just pay somebody to give you
a ride is it okay to go to church if you
have to pay somebody to get you there
well you know I think if that's the only
way that you can get to church is to pay
someone to get you there
that's okay ideally what you'd want to
do in the best case scenario it would be
nice if you could have I know some folks
go to church and they have to use public
transportation like a bus or a train and
they'll try and buy a ticket that is
good for a week or two or whatever the
case might be so that they don't
necessarily have to buy something on the
Sabbath but if that is the only means to
get to church is to pay a taxi drive to
get you there I think it's important for
you to go to church matter of fact the
Bible says we are not to neglect the
gathering of ourselves together so if
that's part of what's needed to get to
church
I wouldn't feel guilty about that I know
I've had to travel before and I've
actually had to pay a toll to get to the
church on Sabbath morning to cross over
a bridge you go through a tunnel and you
know what do you do you you got to do it
you need to get to church I think that's
very important that's actually what the
Bible tells us to do get to church this
does not help it does but you know I've
just been torn because you know it's
testing the fourth commandment we're not
supposed to work or what our managers or
me teachers work I'm so like if I do
this I'm paying somebody to work yeah
well bill you know what are we gonna run
out of time let me comment on that
quickly without a doubt we want to do
everything we can to minimize what
others have to do on Sabbath but and it
comes to coming to church that is rather
important and we want to try all we can
to prearranged
we'll be right back after the break stay
tuned Bible answers live will return in
a moment
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with a Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website at amazing facts dot o-r-g
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation and even discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love
then what went wrong if you've missed
any of our amazing facts programs visit
our website at amazing facts org there
you'll find an archive of all our
television and radio programs including
amazing facts presents one location so
many possibilities amazing facts org
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 source
on line we have a number of resources
that would also make available to you so
with your Bible question then I'm gonna
call 804 six three seven two nine seven
a next caller is Merle listening from
Arkansas Merle welcome to the program
yes thank you
my question is regarding homosexuality
so that we may give directions by the
Word of God alright so there are quite a
few verses in the Bible that deal with
this but probably one of the clearest
that we have is first Corinthians if
you're writing this down first
Corinthians chapter 6 verse and 9 he's
pretty clear I'm gonna read this for
everyone again this is what the Bible
says do you not know that the
unrighteous will not inherit the kingdom
of God do not be deceived neither
fornicators nor idolaters nor adulterers
nor homosexuals nor sodomites nor
thieves nor covetous nor drunkards nor
revilers nor extortioners will inherit
the kingdom of God then in verse 11 it
says and such were some of you but you
were washed but you were sanctified you
were justified in the name of the Lord
Jesus by the spirit of our God
here the Bible makes it clear that
homosexuality is not part of God's
original plan it is a sin according to
the Bible the good news though is that
God does forgive and if there is genuine
repentance and someone turns from sin of
course God is willing to forgive and he
does forgive and I think that's what we
see in 1st Corinthians chapter 6 verse
11 does that help
1st Corinthians chapter 6 and you can
read all the way from verse 9 through to
verse 11 you're welcome thank you for
calling our next call of the behalf is
listening in Charlotte North Carolina I
believe it's lo Lieh
hi and your question this evening
anybody make friends for yourselves the
unrighteous mammon when you fade out yes
well let me give you a little bit of the
context of the parable here you finally
in Luke chapter 16 actually starts in
verse 1 and goes all the way through to
verse 13 and like many other parables
that Jesus told there is a deeper lesson
that is being emphasized in the parable
in the story there is a sort a landowner
or a master who has a steward and the
steward has not been very faithful with
the funds that he's master had given to
him to oversee and manage and so he
realizes he's gonna be caught out and he
could very well lose his job so he
actually goes to the people that owe
money to his master and he says to them
listen what do you owe well I owe so
much he says well we'll give you less
instead of a hundred measures of oil go
ahead and why don't you just pay for you
know a smaller amount pay for fifty or
whatever it might be and he goes to all
of the different debtors of his master
and he works out a deal knowing that
he's probably gonna lose his job and at
least then he has a place that he can go
he has a friend he's made a frame for
someone now Jesus uses that not that in
anyway the Bible is condoning that we
should do that kind of thing but the
principle is that this man thought ahead
he thought ahead and he planned
accordingly now if that's what the
wicked would do how much more should the
righteous think ahead and plan we know
that there is a day of judgment that is
coming and our eternal destiny our
eternal life is at stake
shouldn't we also be diligent then to
make friends with our Savior Jesus
shouldn't we put the time in shouldn't
we seek forgiveness and seek His grace
if the wicked prepare for the future how
much more should the righteous prepare
for an eternal future that is the lesson
that Jesus is trying to emphasize using
this story this parable okay thank you
all right absolutely good question next
one of that we have is Chris and he's
listening in Florida
welcome to the program you know Bible
answers live hi Chris you know yes I can
hear you yes this is Chris hi Chris and
your question today yes I have a
question about our body's physical
bodies when we die yes we all know what
well at all what Paul says in
Thessalonians 1 also I just remember
that when we die we are at rest yes I
was waiting for resurrection in judgment
correct but in Philippians 2 or 4 Paul
says that he would rather die and be
with Christ so what do you think what
does he mean by that
okay well Paul also makes it clear that
flesh and blood cannot inherit eternal
life he also says in Corinthians that
these mortal bodies must put on
immortality and that occurs when Jesus
comes the second time when a person dies
their next conscious thought is the
second coming of Christ if they are
believer the next conscious thought is
the presence of God Jesus is right there
in front of them you seated on the cloud
they are resurrected they have been
caught up to meet Jesus in the air and
now hundreds of years could have passed
or 10 15 whatever could have passed
between their death and their
resurrection but they not aware of time
you know when a person dies the Bible
says his thoughts perish he's unaware
that time has gone by so when Paul says
to be absent from the body is to be
present with the Lord he's just talking
about when we die our next conscious
thought is we are present with the Lord
it's the second coming and we are
resurrected not with these mortal bodies
but with the immortal bodies the bodies
that will last throughout all eternity
yes my second question is how could be
so sure that she would be
yeah well you know Paul had the
assurance of salvation which we can have
as well you know the Bible says whoever
believes in Him should not perish but
have everlasting life Paul and near the
end of his life said I fought a good
fight I finished the race
therefore they is laid up for me not
only for me but all of those that love
God a crown of righteousness so Paul was
confident that Jesus is his Lord his
Savior he was looking forward to that
resurrection morning when he would be in
the presence of God now of course that
occurs Paul will be in the presence of
God at the resurrection morning with all
the righteous who are resurrected when
Jesus comes the second time and that is
the whole way the Christian right okay
thank you bye questions thank you very
much all right well thanks for calling
we do have a study guide Chris that
we'll be happy to send you or anyone
wanting to know more about this it's
simply called are the dead really dead
it's an amazing facts study guide to
receive that the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you just asked for the study guide
called are the dead really dead I Mexico
lays James and he's listening from
Florida James welcome to the program
- John how are you doing doing well
thank you
I was calling up to get some advice on
the proper if the risk considered a
proper way when doing communion I had a
new church and it just happened to have
been doing communion that day and I'm
used to community where you have the
unleavened cracker and then you have
your little Club gracious you do the
cracker and then he takes a grape juice
and you know this church had done it was
they had like fresh bread that people
would get off a fragment and then dip it
in the brake juice and just eat a grape
juice so piece of bread and I have a
sure if that is considered the biblical
way
do it for some reason all I could think
of was just thinking about the passage
where Jesus was calling out Judas in the
man that dips his hand with the bread is
the one that was going to betray him so
I want to know what your thoughts were
on that okay good question
first of all if you I'll give you a
passage in just a minute in first
Corinthians 11 but when it comes to
communion at least the type of bread
that's used the communion service is a
replacement for the Passover service of
the Old Testament and in the Passover
service
it was unleavened bread that was used in
the Bible leaven sometimes represents at
least in the Passover contexts
represented sin and of course Christ's
sacrifice he was sinless even though he
bore our sins it was not for any sin
that he had committed so you will find
that in most churches that practice
communion at least according to the
Bible they will use unleavened bread
meaning a bread that does not have heast
in it so usually it's a flat type of
bread now with reference to the order of
eating the bread and drinking the grape
juice again it is unfermented wine
meaning it's grape juice it doesn't at
least probably one of the clearest
admonitions that we find his 1st
Corinthians chapter 11 and verse 23 and
I'll read this James for you and there
are those who are listening this is the
Apostle Paul he says for I received of
the Lord that which also I delivered to
you that the Lord Jesus on the same
night in which he was betrayed he took
bread and when he had given thanks he
broke it and said take eat this is my
body that is broken for you do this in
remembrance of me so here you find the
bread been broken and people eat the
bread then he verse 25 in the same man
he also took the cup after supper saying
this cup is the New Covenant in my blood
this do as often as you drink it in
remembrance of me for as often as you
eat the bread and drink of the cup you
proclaim the Lord's death till he comes
so from this passage it appears to be
the eating of the bread first and then
the drinking of the grape juice second
not necessarily a dipping into the grape
juice I know in our church we have the
bread separate from the grape juice and
we follow the same order that we find
here in 1st Corinthians 11:23
okay yeah that was kind of what I was
thinking along those lines absolutely
and I'm definitely gonna look up that
person first Clinton's and study on that
too I appreciate that
absolutely first Corinthians chapter 11
verse 23 thanks for your call James we
appreciate it
next caller that we have is shamea
listening shamea welcome to the program
hello hi welcome thanks for calling okay
I would like to know yeah my name is
Amaya you know somebody you might have
to turn your radio down I can hear an
echo there in the background sorry that
would be helpful make it easier and your
your question this evening I have a
question because I just met a hideous
twin okay have a atheist man and she
shared a gospel on my snapchat just like
and I like inspiring others my one step
down my role in leading people you know
the right way through like inspirational
like your inspiration okay and your fax
you're kind of wondering a little bit
about how do you share with an atheist
about Jesus is that the question yeah
okay well good question you know of
course we bump into a Thea specially if
we were studying at a secular University
we might find folks who claim to be
atheist you know I think one of the best
ways that we can witness to an atheist
first and foremost is live the teachings
of Jesus that's one thing to claim to be
a Christian if we're not living the
teachings of Christ but if we're living
a consistent Christian life following
the teachings of Jesus first and
foremost with ourselves then we can
speak from a personal experience of
Jesus we could explain to someone that
Jesus is more than just a theoretical
agreement with a set of beliefs but he
is a real person He loves us Jesus died
to save us Jesus gives peace Jesus gives
hope and strength
the most effective witness whether you
work with an atheist or somebody else is
your personal testimony
somebody might argue your theology but
if you're sharing your own experience of
what Jesus has done for you that's very
hard for somebody to argue against so I
think that's where it starts sharing
your own experience your testimony of
what Jesus has done for you and then as
an interest awakens to learn more about
the Bible then what I would do is I'd
direct their attention to some of the
prophecies in the Bible that help to
prove the Bible as true and when people
can see that these prophecies in the
Bible did come true they were fulfilled
then usually they willing to hear more
about what the Bible has to say so first
of all you want to live the teachings of
Jesus secondly you want to be willing to
share a testimony of what Jesus means to
you and then as interest grows you can
direct them to some of the prophetic
passages of the Bible to build
credibility in the scriptures does that
help okay oh yeah
I have a question like what if she says
like she doesn't care what if she
doesn't care well again you know you
can't force someone if they don't want
to hear you're not going to be able to
force them to hear but you can't at
least be the best witness that you can
and look for those opportunities you
know when things open up if you can
share a word of encouragement if you can
give someone a little bit of the hope
that you have in Jesus you pray for the
person and then allow the Holy Spirit to
do its work I work with the spirit to
help and guide in that situation I want
to thank you for your call shamea our
next caller that we have is listening
from Long Island it's um Varys I think
the name is Long Island New York
Amber's a liar yes somebody high ain't
no problem your honor yes how are you
good very good thank you yes my question
comes from Matthew 16 verse 19 okay so
how you wanting to read yeah let me read
it for you it says Matthew chapter 16
verse 19 for those who might be driving
Jesus speaking he's speaking to the
disciples and he says I will
give you the keys of the kingdom of
heaven whatever you bind on earth will
be bound in heaven whatever you loose on
earth will be loosed in heaven and your
question is you wondering what this
means right yes but also I hear someone
using these birds saying that the church
if someone is like removed from the
membership of the church is actually
being removed on the books of heaven
things
this bird is giving that authority to
the church so what you think about that
okay well the authority that Jesus gives
to the church and in a special sense to
his disciples here was the authority to
preach the gospel in preaching the
gospel they were opening the kingdom of
heaven to those who would receive it in
preaching the gospel they were closing
heaven to those who rejected it so the
key is the gospel the preaching of the
gospel is where the disciples were to
fulfill their mission in either opening
heaven or closing heaven depending upon
whether a person received the gospel or
rejected the gospel our eternal
salvation is dependent upon our choice
it's not a decision that somebody else
can make for us it's not a decision that
the church can make on our behalf we
have to personally choose Jesus now
having said that there are times in a
church where perhaps a member needs to
be placed on some type of disciplinary
measure or maybe there's a belief in the
church who is openly living in sin and
the church needs to deal with that
situation there there are some times
where someone's membership might have to
be removed from the church records
that's not removing the name from heaven
it's quite possible though that if the
church has to remove their name from the
church books perhaps they've already
rebelled against God to the point where
they name is already removed from heaven
but it doesn't mean that they lost
forever
I know of many instances where people
they had their names removed from the
church records but as time went on they
came to repentance they acknowledge
their son that confessed to God and they
were reunited with the church
so yeah there's many instances and
experiences where people have had their
so this is not an arbitrary decision
that the church makes as to who's going
to be saved and who's going to be lost
each individual eats make that decision
for themselves okay okay so if a member
to say they don't have time to breathe
baptized and they being they were
removed from church they means they can
be still being saved right
oh absolutely matter of fact the correct
manner of dealing with a member that is
a pasta size meaning they're not
following the teachings of Jesus or the
Bible you deal with them and it's
sometimes you need to remove them from
membership but you do so with the hope
that through that they will realize the
error of their ways and come to a point
of repentance that's the ultimate goal
to bring them to a point of repentance
and then that they would be reunited
okay okay thank you all right thanks
appreciate your call yeah thank you for
your thing absolutely our next caller
that we have is Christopher and I
believe listening from Trinidad
Christopher welcome to the program good
night
yes hi welcome thanks and your question
tonight my question is what is the
importance of the correct understanding
of the Trinity and the divinity of
Christ alright first of all I think
let's deal with the last part of your
question first talking about the
divinity of Jesus I think it's an
important biblical teaching that we need
to recognize that Jesus was indeed God
John chapter one talks about in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God all things were made by him
without him was not anything made that
was made and the word became flesh and
dwelt among us it's clearly talking
about Jesus so it's very clear from the
Bible that Jesus is one with the father
he does share the character qualities of
being divine he is God and then also the
Holy Spirit we find in the New Testament
also sharing those same qualities of the
so the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit they're all divine does that help
Christopher yeah no now the question you
had is how important is it for us to
understand that yeah okay the correct
understanding of the Trinity well you
know I think first of first of all you
know God reveals truth to us and
depending upon how we respond to that
truth is important we might not at first
have a full or correct understanding of
the Godhead and I don't think anyone has
a complete understanding of who God is
and we're talking about God the creator
of the universe but what has been
revealed to us in the Bible we ought to
seek that out and then accept that as
revealed in the Bible we might not be
able to explain it or understand it
fully I mean how can we try and
comprehend the fact that God has no
beginning from a human perspective
that's very hard to try and wrap our
mind around that God is always being he
has no beginning because we live in a
world that is about beginnings and
endings but this is something that the
Bible says and so because it says that
in the Bible we accept it we believe it
we take it as as the Bible reads and I
think that's the most important when we
talk about this subject is recognizing
there are areas that we do not
understand but also then accepting those
clear things that are expressed in
Scripture and you know Christopher we do
have a book that we'll be happy to send
you matter of fact you could probably
read it for free online at the amazing
facts web site the book is called the
Trinity is it biblical again it's called
the Trinity is it biblical or you can
call and ask for the book the number is
883 five six seven four seven and anyone
is listening you can call and ask for
the book is the Trinity biblical and
we'll be happy to send that to you our
next caller is Thomas listening in
Toronto Canada Thomas welcome to the
program yes how are you doing doing well
and your question this evening yes this
is my question in the Bible it talks
about that the divine punishment was
though we return to dust right
and I understand that like seventh-day
Adventists don't believe in the immortal
soul neither do I sir so we so we do
indeed return to dust and this isn't
misses my question because when I called
in I said is Jesus oxygen and this is
something that I came to understand when
you look at the periodic table carbon is
has six electrons six protons and six
neutrons and carbon is the basis of all
life basically you can call carbon dust
and oxygen has 8 electrons 8 protons and
eight neutrons right okay when you add
up Jesus's name in Greek and the New
Testament was written in Greek it adds
up to eight eight eight and that's the
same as oxygen okay and so are you
saying Jesus is oxygen or just that he's
like oxygen Jesus would be that living
tree it produces the spiritual oxygen
for us to live it okay yeah I can see
what you're saying yeah let me say
something about that it is remarkable
you have the creation story it says God
formed Adam out of the dust of the earth
out of the clay so you have you know the
physical matter then it says and God
breathed into Adam the breath of life
and Adam became a living being now we
know oxygen is essential for human life
and yet with the life that Jesus gave
Adam this breath of life it was
something more than just oxygen although
oxygen is needed but it's that spark of
life you can have a dead person and you
can pump as much oxygen in them as you
like it's not necessarily going to bring
them back to life unless there is that
narrow window of opportunity so in some
ways you can think of the life-giving
power as oxygen but God is of course so
much more than oxygen but it is an
interesting connection there to think of
God we we need oxygen every day to
breathe so we need Jesus every day
spiritually to breathe and just as
oxygen brings life and strength so Jesus
brings life and strength to those who
believe in him well I want to thank you
for your call Thomas I'm looking at the
clock frames and it doesn't look like we
have time to take another
and if you're still waiting we want to
thank you for your patience I'll be sure
to call as next week
and we'll be able to take more of your
Bible answers but until then I'd like to
remind you of some of the great
resources that are available at the
amazing facts website if you haven't
visited the website lately I'd encourage
you to take a look at it it's just
recently being designed redesigned it's
got a lot of great resources especially
for those who'd like to study deep in
what the Bible teaches just go to
amazing facts dot o-r-g and you'll be
able to get a lot more information there
at our website and while you're there
you can click on some of the earlier
Bible answer live programs and listen
god bless thank you for listening to
today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
once an old God's plan for our world and
solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
com or by calling 805 three eight seven
two seven five okay friends let's start
with the basics we know we're here but
we're not here for very long so the most
important thing would be if we could
learn during this life how to live
forever this is the central focus of
amazing facts there's a lot of wonderful
things that Christian ministries do I
believe in Christian education but if
the schools lose the message of
salvation
you end up with more educated sinners I
think it's very important for us to
build churches but if the churches lose
the message of salvation they just
become buildings and shells I think it's
important to have a medical ministry and
build hospitals but if they separate
that from the message of salvation you
just prolong a sinners life for a little
while that's why for years amazing facts
has made it our focus to present the
saving truth that sets people free and
Friends we want to thank you for your
support in your gifts we'll do our very
best to convert those resources into the
currency of heaven may God bless you and
keep amazing facts in your prayers did
you know that Noah was present to the
birth of Abraham okay maybe he wasn't in
the room but he was alive and probably
telling stories about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of Revelation Bible
history calm is a free resource where
you can explore major Bible events and
characters enhance your knowledge of the
Bible and draw closer to God's Word go
deeper visit Bible History com4
life-changing Christian resources this
@af bookstore calm
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at
www.lazyguycooking.com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
you